has a lot of implications
to actual future application in architecture,
and in this case, here you see a house,
that's for a developer in China,
and it's actually a four-story glass box.
It's still with that glass box because we still want that visual access,
but now it's sheathed with this thermo-bimetal layer,
it's a screen that goes around it, and that layer can actually
open and close as that sun moves around on that surface.
In addition to that, it can also screen areas for privacy,
so that it can differentiate from some of the public areas
in the space during different times of day.
And what it basically implies is that, in houses now,
we don't need drapes or shutters or blinds anymore
because we can sheath the building with these things,
as well as control the amount of air conditioning you need inside that building.
I'm also looking at trying to develop some building components for the market,
and so here you see a pretty typical
double-glazed window panel, and in that panel,
between those two pieces of glass, that double-glazing,
I'm trying to work on making
a thermo-bimetal pattern system
so that when the sun hits that outside layer
and heats that interior cavity, that thermo-bimetal
will begin to curl, and what actually will happen then
is it'll start to block out the sun
in certain areas of the building,
and totally, if necessary.
And so you can imagine, even in this application, that
in a high-rise building where the panel systems go
from floor to floor up to 30, 40 floors, the entire surface
could be differentiated at different times of day
depending on how that sun moves across and hits that surface.
And these are some later studies that I'm working on
right now that are on the boards, where you can see,
in the bottom right-hand corner, with the red, it's actually
smaller pieces of thermometal, and it's actually going to,
we're trying to make it move like cilia or eyelashes.
This last project is also of components.
The influence -- and if you have noticed, one of my
spheres of influence is biology -- is from a grasshopper.
And grasshoppers have a different kind of breathing system.
They breathe through holes in their sides called spiracles,
and they bring the air through and it moves through their system to cool them down,
and so in this project, I'm trying to look at how we can
consider that in architecture too, how we can bring
air through holes in the sides of a building.
And so you see here some early studies of blocks,
where those holes are actually coming through,
and this is before the thermo-bimetal is applied,
and this is after the bimetal is applied. Sorry, it's a little
hard to see, but on the surfaces, you can see these red arrows.
On the left, it's when it's cold and the thermo-bimetal
is flat so it will constrict air from passing through the blocks,
and on the right, the thermo-bimetal curls
and allows that air to pass through, so those are two different
components that I'm working on, and again,
it's a completely different thing, because you can imagine
that air could potentially be coming through the walls
instead of opening windows.
So I want to leave you with one last impression about
the project, or this kind of work and using smart materials.
When you're tired of opening and closing those blinds
day after day, when you're on vacation
and there's no one there on the weekends to be turning off and on the controls,
or when there's a power outage, and you have
no electricity to rely on, these thermo-bimetals
will still be working tirelessly, efficiently
and endlessly. Thank you. (Applause)
(Applause)